this program is brought to you by Emory
University ever since I came to college
I've been practicing martial arts a lot
more than in high school I guess and
been reading a lot more about martial
arts philosophy and books on it and I
really I guess just noticed through
reading and research that there's always
comparisons between martial arts in the
environment I figured be cool to do a
writing like a independent research
writing requirement on it and just see
what I could come up with normally every
martial art or normally draw a
comparison to water ocean dough will
work is one of the ones that focuses on
all all the elements and really ties
them into martial arts moves and
emotions and physical attributes I got
with my professors dr. sizing Carl Brown
and we really just outlined what we
thought the connections would be and we
just made a huge list going from animal
behaviors to humans working with the
environment invasive species is a new
one we're looking at correspondences
between how people deal with invasive
species and martial artists dealing with
weapons introduced I mean the adaptive
cycle parallels how an ecosystem adapts
and evolves to changes and the same
thing goes along with martial artists
while either with their personal
training and how they have to go
developing techniques and themselves or
when they're working with a partner
there's always constant constant change
and constant development when either
inspiring or just in practice in
training a lot of sword movements
especially try to be flowing and
continuous not mainly parallels water
especially for block you want to move
with the opponent and other other moves
with sword parallel to fire where
they're very aggressive and they're very
quick trying to move into your opponent
and end it as quickly as possible while
water is more retreating and defensive
this will definitely be a project that I
hopefully get to continue to expand and
work with new ideas always keep coming
up with more correspondences and more
refining of ideas the preceding program
is copyrighted by Emory University